- There are days in every child's life
that change who they are forever.
- "Becoming You" is about
the developmental steps
kids go through
between birth and 2,000 days,
going from this helpless newborn,
to the most sophisticated animal
on the planet.
And we wanted to
capture that journey.
- We had to go and get
the best teams from around the world
to bring this level
of beauty on the screen.
- It's an extraordinarily
difficult show to make.
We filmed over 100 children
in 11 countries, 250 days globally.
- We're shooting this in large format,
which is new in
the documentary sphere.
Visually, it's pretty breathtaking,
but technically, quite a challenge
when shooting multi-locations,
underwater elements,
going across
all four corners of the globe.
But also working with children.
It's immensely complicated.
- Yah!
- Ready? Roll camera?
- There was a lot of times
kids don't want to do
the behavior you're trying to capture.
- No.
- Like, naps are my enemy.
- Aah!
- Take nine!
- And that's the real challenge.
You can plan for it
and hope it's going to go like this,
but on the day, it's life.
We're not making this up.
We're just here to film it.
♪ Can we keep our dreams alive ♪
- This is one of the biggest things
you can possibly do
in documentary filmmaking.
The team really did
an incredible job.
- And you're like, "Oh, my God,
this is totally worth it."
- It really shows that we're all going on
the same amazing journey,
and I think it's really remarkable.
♪ Can we keep our dreams alive ♪
- This is the extraordinary story
all about us.
- Hi.